Okay, Dr. Zakir, in the morning of the
Eid,
is a requirement for the Muslims to go
out and do the Eid prayer. Could you
explain for the benefit of myself and
the viewers,
what are the rulings regarding the Eid
prayer?
As far as the prayer for Eid is
concerned, our beloved Prophet Muhammad
said
It's mentioned in Sahih Muslim, volume
number two, in the book of fasting,
Hadith number 2534. Abu Hurairah, may
Allah be pleased with him, he said
that Prophet Muhammad said
he said that fasting is prohibited on
two days, on Eid al-Fitr
and Eid al-Adha. That means on the two
days of Eidain
Eid al-Fitr, that's breaking of the
fast, and Eid day of Adha, that's the
Eid day of sacrifice. These two days
it's prohibited. So, no one can fast on
these two days.
As far as the ruling is concerned about
the salah for Eid al-Fitr, there's
difference of opinion amongst the
scholars and the different schools of
thought. According to Imam Shafi and
Imam Malik
the Shafi'is and the Malikis, they say
that the Eid salah is a sunnah
mu'akkadah.
It is a very important sunnah known as
mustahab.
Based on the Hadith
that the Bedouin who comes and says
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has not
made us compulsory any salah
other than the five prescribed salah.
Which is mentioned in Mughni, volume
number two, page number 223. So, based
on this Hadith that no other salah is
compulsory besides the five times
prescribed salah they say that this
salah of Eid al-Fitr and Eid al-Adha
it is sunnah mu'akkadah.
According to the Hanbali school of
thought
the Hanbalis, they say it is fard
al-kifayah. That means it's a fard as
long as some people from the community
do it, it's enough. It's not fard on
every individual, fard al-kifayah.
And the third ruling
that is according to Imam Abu Hanifah,
may Allah have mercy on him, he said
that it is fard, it is wajib. And this
view is also of Sheikh Ibn Taymiyyah
that
praying Eid al-Fitr salah and Eid
al-Adha salah, it is fard.
And the ruling is based on the verse of
the Quran of Surah Kawthar, chapter
number 108, verse number two, which says
Inna a'tainaka al-Kawthar, fasalli li
rabbika wanhar.
Fasalli li rabbika wanhar means and turn
to the Lord
in prayer and sacrifice.
So, it indicates that you have to offer
the Eid salah of
Eid al-Adha and then sacrifice.
So, based on this verse they say it is
compulsory to offer the Eid salah. And
there are various other Sahih Hadith in
which Prophet Muhammad said has
commanded
the Muslims that they should offer
salah, not only to the Muslim even to
the women who are menstruating, he said
go for Eid salah even if you don't have
to offer salah.
He said the veiled women, even the
virgin, whether they are young or
matured, they should go for Eid salah.
And the menstruating women, even if they
can't offer, they should at least go to
the musalla. It's mentioned in Sahih
Bukhari, volume number one
in the book of
salah, Hadith number
351 as well as Hadith number 324. And
various other Hadiths.
The Prophet even said that the children
should go.
And based on this Hadith, Imam Abu
Hanifah may Allah have mercy on him and
Sheikh Ibn Taymiyyah
may Allah have mercy on him, too
they said that offering Eid salah is
fard. There's one more Hadith in Sunan
Abu Dawud, volume number one, in the
book of salah, Hadith number 1068
where the beloved Prophet Muhammad said
that
we have two Eids together
that is Eid al-Fitr
and the Jumu'ah salah.
And Jumu'ah is supposed to be a week
Eid.
So, he says
that after offering the Eid al-Fitr
salah, he says that those who do not
want to offer Jumu'ah salah may not do
it if they don't want to. But
we will offer Jumu'ah salah.
Indicating that because you offered Eid
al-Fitr, Jumu'ah salah, which is more
important
than the five prescribed salah
here Prophet said if you offer Eid
al-Fitr in congregation
Jumu'ah salah may not be offered that
day. But naturally they have to offer
the normal Dhuhr salah.
So, this
surely indicates that Eid al-Fitr is
a fard salah. And I agree with the view
of Imam Abu Hanifah, may Allah have
mercy on him, as well as Sheikh Ibn
Taymiyyah, may Allah have mercy on him,
too.